[Music]
so
i know what you're thinking a lone rider
a dystopian world a land that's
gone to waste how did this world
get so broken well
that all began 500 years ago
[Music]
kumandra
this is what we used to be when our land
was whole
and we lived harmoniously alongside
dragons magical creatures who brought us
water
and rain and peace
it was paradise but then
the drone came
a mindless plague that spread like
wildfire
multiplying as they consumed life and
turned everyone they touched
into stone the dragons fought for us the
best they
could but
it wasn't enough
that's when the mighty sisu. the last
dragon
concentrated all her magic into a gem
and
blasted the drone away
everyone that was turned to stone came
back
except the dragons
all that was left of sisu was her gem it
should have been this big
inspirational moment where humanity
united over her sacrifice
but instead people being people
they all fought to possess the last
remnant of dragon magic
borders were drawn kumandra divided
we all became enemies and the gem had to
be hidden
but that's not how the world broke that
didn't truly happen until 500 years
later
when i came into the story
[Music]
[Music]
huh looks like someone's trying to be
clever
all right duck took let's show my clever
really looks like
[Music]
come on focus
thank you
hey bud that was awesome give me some
shelf
i gotcha
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait a second
this feels too easy
[Music]
chief benjamin i know it's your job to
try and stop me but
you won't don't mistake spirit for skill
young one
i promise you will not set foot on the
dragon gems inner circle
not even a toe you might want to take
out that blade
you're gonna need it not today
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
like i said not one foot on the inner
circle
you lost raya did i
mariah i probably should have said two
feet
hey don't beat yourself up too much
chief benja
you gave it your best i won't
and it's either father or bad to you
you did good dewdrop you're passed the
test
wow the spirit
of sisu
[Music]
for generations our family has sworn to
protect the gem
today you will join that legacy
raya princess of heart
my daughter you are now a guardian of
the dragon gem
[Music]
see what happens next order the entire
movie disney's riya and the last dragon
now available